all right we're live now for another
live reading from my book reason
fulfilled by revelation the 1930s
christian philosophy debates in france
and today we're going to be looking at a
bit of a longer section it's turning up
the lights here it's really dingy and
gloomy here today in milwaukee you might
hear some rain on the skylights coming
through it's been raining off and on
all morning long so
the section that we're starting now is a
turning point in the book um
i mean this this is not a drama or
anything
but
it's this part right here the debates
expand
1932 to 1933
and so this represents an important
period in the debates the initial
sort of sorting things out and getting
everybody into
uh lines with each other the debates
drew in a whole bunch of other people
who were not initially
involved in these christian philosophy
debates and among them were
um gabriel marcel who we're going to be
reading
shortly
reading from shortly my translation of
gabrielle marcel and
his piece is titled
regarding the spirit of medieval
philosophy
by mr etienne jill soam
and it's published in a journal that
didn't really last all that long
which is called la nouvelle review de
june
and it was published in 1932 so this is
a book review but this is not
you know just a book review uh you know
saying oh the book talks about this and
that this is a philosophical book review
where instead um
you you get to like say a few things
about the the topic the problems and
that's what marcel does he in effect
sketches out a
new position on christian philosophy
that in some respects goes beyond the
energy also and in some respects goes
beyond that of
blondel so here is part one it was
published in two parts so we're going to
read each of the two parts
today mr etienne gilson gives us the ten
lectures delivered last year at the
university of aberdeen the gifford
lectures under the title the spirit of
medieval philosophy this course is
extended this year by a second series of
lectures so that the book will have a
successor bearing on christian politics
and morals
in reality the problem mr jilson has
dedicated himself to resolving by
resting on that imposing
body of work he's dedicated to the
philosophy of the middle ages and two
its underground prolongations within the
heart of cartesianism itself is one
possessing clear parameters
this problem is the very same one
on which mr emil bravier had staked out
a clear position in a well-noted article
published in the april june 1931
reviewed metaphysique morale and in an
address made around the same time
to the society frances de philosophy
is there mr brayer asks a christian
philosophy what is christianity's
positive role in the development of
philosophical thought
his response was the most radically
negative one that could be conceived it
is important to cite several lines from
his conclusion
quote it is by accident that during the
centuries of the middle ages
intellectual culture of greek origin was
closely tied to religious profession
philosophy at the end of antiquity was
platonist aristotle's rationalism
dominated the 13th century in the 17th
century a new intellectualism was born
issued from the greek genius in the 19th
century social problems imposed
themselves by the antithesis of
sociocracy and individualism
this development is independent of
christianity it did not have the least
affinity with it we have seen
christianity's attempts always vain to
fix on one of these moments in order to
appropriate it but one can no more speak
of a christian philosophy
than of a christian
mathematics or a christian physics
if this thesis which i hasten to say
seems absurd to me was established
historically
we should not conceal from ourselves the
fact that it would risk entailing the
most serious perhaps the most ruinous
consequences for religion itself i
insist on this here knowing full
knowing perfectly well that there are
some neo-scholastic thinkers who
maintain that the concept of christian
philosophy is obviously void of meaning
if it was admitted
that christianity has had no positive
influence on philosophical development
this would entail saying that it has
never actually been able to be thought
for there is no thought worthy of that
name that does not contribute to
transforming all the other thoughts it
is not a matter here of poured concrete
cells or sealed compartments to say that
christianity has never been thought is
to let it be understood that it is not
thinkable that for human reason taking
this word in as wide as signification
christianity constitutes a sort of
perfectly opaque foreign body
we would
thus be given to believe
that christian faith faith and revealed
data cannot in any manner organize
itself together with the totality of
human experience insofar as human
experience itself elaborates and
elucidates itself
from there it takes only one step to
consider christian faith to be an
anomaly something simply vestigial at
least let us not mean to say that
christianity has confined itself to
presenting
under a metaphorical or symbolic form an
ensemble of moral or even metaphysical
truths that human thought would have
been perfectly able to grasp by its own
means
then it is the very originality of the
christian revelation that is contested
we are i would say in the presence of a
dilemma
either
if there is no christian philosophy we
must resolve to admit either that the
content of revelation is unable to be
assimilated by the mind
or that it is deprived of all
authenticities nothing but a fallacious
trusty of certain purely rational
evidence aside from these the only
recourse would be to claim that
christianity is not a doctrine at all
but a life attitude
there is little need to underscore how
ruinous and how radically contrary to
the essential principles of catholicism
a position
like this is
for my part i think then perhaps more
than mr jill so himself this problem is
important for christianity and it would
be madness to want to elude it under the
pretext that history is the domain of
hypotheses and that there where serious
interests are in play it is preferable
not to engage yourselves in adventures
for this quest
mr joseoh is an incomparable guide
he is at the same time
a historian of the first rank and an
authentic christian and i think that
these two qualities are equally required
here
contrary to a prejudice that ought to be
pulled out by the roots it is in
infinitely dubious that in an order of
questions of this sort the quote
scientific character could be rigorously
isolated from what i will dare to call
its personal context without any damage
to the research itself
any specialist whatsoever with as many
university diplomas and certificates as
you like is not to the same degree
is not in every consciousness
susceptible of apprehending a certain
kind of truths that total kylo to send
pure and simple uncovering of a date of
a location the simple determination of
an objective connection the separation
mr brayer crudely imposes on saint
augustine's works between his philosophy
that of plato and platinus and his
christian faith
simply gives one the meaning that this
historian whose knowledge and probity
nobody can test is entirely
incapable of penetrating into a doctrine
where precisely the elements his
analysis dissociates are
intimately grounded mr josoul who in
contrast communicates with
augustinianism from the inside
has exerted the most noteworthy efforts
to show how in the works of the great
doctors and perhaps above all in saint
thomas's works notions borrowed from
greek philosophy were affected by a
radically new index that deeply modifies
their nature
by merely going on to inventories by
placing isolated terms in conflict
rather than ideas one cannot hope to
reach this living truth that
even be and perhaps before everything
else
is the only important one for philosophy
in the spirit of medieval philosophy one
finds that sort of sympathy that
includes neither fervor nor respect and
that already gave so much value to the
christian philosophy of saint augustine
an attitude that in my view is
rigorously required in matters of this
type of order but that i fear mr brahier
would judge incompatible with the
demands or the privileges of a strictly
objective method as if in similar
matters the very meaning of the word
object objectivity did not demand to be
deepened and relentlessly renewed
here i cannot i clearly cannot summarize
this magisterial book whose expression
is the most remarkable density i would
only like to shed light on several
points that seem to me particularly
important
before researching how a saint augustine
a saint bonaventure a saint thomas have
innovated on specifically philosophical
terrain in relation to the thinkers of
antiquity mr gilson will ask quote the
first philosophers to turn christian
what they gained
as philosophers in so doing
insofar as philosophers if mr brahier
were right this question would not have
any meaning at all
and consequently would admit of no
solution but here we have
extraordinarily precise and positive
witnesses in particular that of saint
justin whose dialogue with trifo is of
the first order of importance in this
dialogue saint justin actually recounts
how an old man encountered by chance
revealed to him the existence and
writings of the prophets he explained
that quote they did not use
demonstration in their treatises seeing
that they were witnesses to the truth
above all demonstration and worthy of
belief and saint justin declares quote
whilst revolving his words in my mind i
found this philosophy alone to be safe
and profitable thus and for this reason
i am a philosopher
jutos kai dia tauta philosophos ego this
phrase suffices to do justice to the
arbitrary distinction introduced by mr
bragiere
as mr jill saul says a man seeks the
truth by the unaided effort of reason
and is disappointed it is offered him by
faith and he accepts and having accepted
he finds that it satisfies his reason
it seems to me one might make it even
more precise the contribution here is a
certain datum
a revealed datum whose signification
whose value is absolutely transcendent
to any experience susceptible of being
constituted on purely
human bases
there is the paradox the scandal if you
like
i would be disposed for my part to think
that there is christian philosophy
only where this paradox this scandal is
not only admitted or even accepted but
embraced with a passionate and
unrestricted gratitude
from the moment on when to the contrary
philosophy seeks by some procedure to
attenuate this
scandal to mask the paradox to reabsorb
the revealed datum in a dialectic of
pure reason or mind to this precise
degree it ceases to be a christian
philosophy
along these lines very close to us the
extraordinary influence exercise by
kierkegaard in reaction to hegelian
idealism is in is explicable
that is a key point to which i will soon
return once the translations currently
being done have appeared those of
sickness unto death repetition and the
concept of anxiety
if i had to address a criticism to mr
jill saul
it would be perhaps that of not placing
this paradox at the heart of the
definition he gives to christian
philosophy here is his definition quote
i call christian every philosophy which
although keeping the two orders distinct
never nevertheless considers the
christian revelation as an indispensable
auxiliar auxiliary to reason
cannot help myself from finding this
word auxiliary insufficient a christian
philosophy seems to me to be defined by
the fact that it finds its ontological
gripping point in a unique fact by which
i mean one without any analog and that
is the incarnation
perhaps it would not be abusive to claim
that the essence of such a philosophy is
a meditation on that datums implications
and consequences of every order not only
unpredictable but contrary to reasons
superficial demands from the very start
wrongly
posing themselves as inviolable but the
essential
function of metaphysical reflection
will consist in critiquing those demands
in the name of higher demands and
consequently in the name of a superior
reason that faith in the incarnation
puts precisely in the condition of
becoming
fully conscious of itself
it would be quite wrong however to to
strictly localize christian philosophy's
specific contribution the central light
residing in the incarnation
radiates in reality through all the
regions of metaphysics and these are
precisely the multiple or even
indefinite radiations that mr jill so
has stirred to recognize to in the
course of his research
along these lines he will show us more
emphatically how the notion of being
itself in the works of the doctors of
the church profoundly differentiates
itself from that which was already in
aristotle's works this point is just as
essential to establish as the one for
example that is widely enough granted
that saint thomas says purely and simply
reappropriated the aristotelian ontology
for his his own
ego
the eternal says to moses and here we
are at the source of all the christian
doctrine it is in this way that saint
augustine will declare regarding god
known aliquo moto est said est est god
is being and by starting from that point
the doctors were led to set him as
infinite and as perfect at the same time
in any case these two characters
necessarily imply each other
but for aristotle as mr gilson
underscores if god is among all the
beings the one that merits par
excellence the word being his polytheism
prevents him from conceiving the divine
as something other than the attribute of
a class of beings
the first unmoved mover the most divine
being the being that is most being
remains one of several beings
insofar
as beings perhaps i sh would not be so
categorical with mr joson no one rises
he says to the christian conception of
being who sets up statues to zeus and
demeter
it is in reality very difficult to know
at what point aristotle's polytheism was
a belief that is something other than a
habitus of social man i'm not even sure
that we will not be tempted here to put
the problem in terms answering to an
entire system of strictly modern
psychological conditions or categories
but where mr zhilson is right
is when he makes us note that in
aristotle's system
the first name of god is thought and
pure being is reduced to pure thought
whereas in good christian doctrine the
first name of god is being
in a very important note he also points
out that all that is equivocal in the
expression
that is the the divine the genre of
metaphysical beings
doubtless the radical novelty here is
the transcendence of being in relation
to attributes whatever they may be
am i then deceiving myself by noting
that this transcendence in relation to
attributes is already the divine freedom
is already the person
here it is quite clear that we are in a
zone foreign to greek thought it will
still remain possible to admit that
aristotle's deep and so original views
on the transcendentals were in some
manner pre-ordained in relation to an
ontology whose vital hearth is to be
found elsewhere but that in order to be
established in a doctrine had to use
transforming them in both
both intimate and first and sensible way
the logical tools greece placed at its
service
i don't know if mr gilsau would go so
far as i in this direction but i
would be born far enough to admit that
the notion of christian philosophy
is susceptible of taking on a meaning
only for a consciousness if not
christian at least impregnated by
christianity by that very fact but
capable of apprehending the development
of doctrines following perspectives not
absolutely coinciding with those of the
historian pure and simple perhaps this
development itself for one who truly
arrives at grasping it in its deepest
interior
participates in the characters specific
to the highest religious life perhaps
the interlocking chain of a saint
augustine
st thomas's a saint bonaventures highest
speculations reconnects to some degree
with that sacred history of which we
have lost almost even the notion in
these times of excessive and brutal
secularization
by this due to her we would come back to
a sort of providentialism which we must
however keep ourselves from allowing to
flow into two massive and too simplistic
formulas and of which the hegelian
conception that is dialectical of the
history of philosophy would appear both
as a fallacious enough transposition and
as an approximation an instructive one
nevertheless
the philosophical problem that the very
existence of a history of philosophy
raises is one that in our days its
specialists seem the most incapable of
laying out or even suspecting
nevertheless whatever system one may
adopt it remains an absolutely
fundamental problem and one that for a
christian takes the sharpest value the
most tragic signification an electable
problem that our other catholic
philosophers are kept considering face
on and with a relentless gaze
all right on to part two
of uh gabriel marcel's review regarding
the spirit of medieval philosophy
published in la la nouvelle
the second series of gifford lectures mr
gilson has delivered on the spirit of
medieval philosophy has just appeared it
presents an interest at least equal to
the first furthermore it provides a very
precise response that as far as i'm
concerned seems also a perfectly
satisfactory response to the problem mr
brejier initially raised as to the
existence of an authentic christian
philosophy
here i will discuss only the last
lecture bearing on the middle ages and
philosophy because within the limits of
a short article such as this there can
be no question of entering into the
detail the marvelously marvelously clear
at least in general expositions mr
jillson is devoted to self-knowledge to
knowledge of things to the intellect and
its object to the free will and to
christian freedom to law and to
christian morality and finally to
intention to conscience and to
obligation
i would like to confine myself here
to specifying the general solution the
author contributes to a problem that
exhibits a major importance for us and
for today's philosophy
mr gilson notes that medieval philosophy
has given rise to two types of basic
objections surprising to see often
presented concurrently since it is clear
they mutually exclude each other
sometimes one will accuse saint
augustine or saint thomas of having
confined himself to reproducing theses
borrowed from the philosophy of
antiquity though not without having
weighed them down with mistakes that
deeply alter them
other times they will be criticized
because the essence of philosophy was
dissolved and allowed to be lost in
religion in the first case they're
accused of having compromised
christianity's essence precisely to the
degree they would proceed as
philosophers and enroll themselves in
the school of the ancients
in the second case they cannot be
pardoned for having sacrificed
philosophy to christianity's religious
demands i will observe as well that when
mr brejier writes that one can no more
speak of a christian philosophy then of
a christian mathematics or a christian
physics it is clear he does not set out
this impossibility in history's name
properly speaking but rather in the name
of the notions themselves for him
history contributes only a completely
negative
confirmation
one with which this judgment could in
the end dispense mr jill so has engaged
in efforts to establish grounding
himself on the facts that is on the
reality of what was actually thought by
philosophers of the middle ages that
historical truth passes precisely
between
these obvious contradictories
the criticism
of having sacrificed too much to
philosophy is not of a particularly
recent date it's worth noting noting
that it is in luther's work that it was
formulated with the most venomous and
rigor for luther not only is
christianity not a philosophy but there
will never be any philosophy fit to call
itself compatible with the gospel
but this accusation clearly cannot be
brought except from an extra and even
anti-philosophical point of view and one
can add that in reality it presupposes a
preliminary disqualification of reason
for a philosopher the converse criticism
presents an entirely different
seriousness no doubt about it
at its base mr zhilson's position
consists in admitting on the one hand
that the existence of a christian
philosophy was inevitable
at least in fact because christianity
after all comes to fill in nature
and that nature is the proper object of
philosophy but on the other hand
it did not have to modify philosophy by
adding a new system to other
pre-existing systems but rather by
transcending
all of them
quote after as before the coming of
christ philosophers had no other
technical data at their disposal than
the patiently accumulated results of the
labor of the greeks if they made these
their starting points it was because
there was no other possible starting
point for them their religion brought
with it no new philosophy but it made
them new men and the new birth affected
in themselves was bound to bring about a
renaissance of philosophy which to say
the truth was sadly in need of it
from that point on the renewal of
philosophical thought in the middle ages
must be regarded as having been produced
within the very limits in which it was
conceivable can we imagine a philosophy
that while being a philosophy in the
rigorously rational sense of the term
had integrated within itself
all those transcendent and specifically
supernatural experiences which belong of
right to christianity and constitute its
religious essence
but without a doubt this integration
itself cannot be conceived without
contradiction
even a christian philosophy says mr
joseon can well find a place in the
edifice of christian wisdom but it will
never be the equivalent of christian
wisdom to demand of a part that would
absorb and remain faithful to its
essence all the while is to destroy at
once the part and the whole this seems
to me
admirably said
perhaps though there would be room to
dig deeper
claiming to integrate transcendent and
specifically supernatural evidences
which belong of right to christianity is
without any doubt a contradictory
undertaking
about whose development german
philosophy of religion provides us with
quite re instructive examples
to the contrary the idea of a
secondation of reason by dogma and even
more precisely by an experience
for itself is clarified as possible of
the religious and even sacramental life
does not seem to me to be able to
support any valid objection
and i'm very happy to see that mr
jillson himself admits this fee
condition as definitively as possible
referring actually to the remarks i i
believe needed to be made about the
first series he writes this
the sole line of demarcation which in my
view must be scrupulously maintained is
the line that separates a
rationalization of dogma and an
evacuation of mystery from the fee
condition of reason by dogma this
fertile this former enterprise i should
regard as illegitimate no possible
dispute on this point i believe
theology utilizes rational concepts for
the purpose of locating and defining the
mystery it cannot set out to make it
comprehensible aristotle was never used
to explain transubstantiation but rather
to make clear what is required if
transubstantiation is to take place
quite obvious to explain trump's
transubstantiation is to claim in some
way to reproduce it ideally
and thus to deny it while believing to
uphold it and to render oneself culpable
at the same time of an absurdity and a
sacrilege quote on the contrary when
dogma comes to the aid of reason
it loses nothing of its transcendence no
more than grace does when it comes to
the aid of man
but mr jill so adds in the very heart of
the contribution furnished by revelation
we must distinguish between truths
entirely rationalizable on the one hand
and mysterious facts in themselves on
the other hand in which reason discovers
the authentic solution the only possible
solution of its problems for example
creation and finally such dogmas whose
essence man cannot understand nor even
show they would be rationally demandable
in so far as facts for example the
incarnation
quote
we need not suppose that philosophy has
nothing to gain by meditating on such
things perhaps precisely by doing so it
will attain to a greater comprehension
of its own deepest truths but the fact
that they open up transcendent
perspectives which may go to complete
philosophy will never in the least
diminish the mysterious character of
these revealed truths
here again i am in agreement with mr
zhilson it cannot be a question in any
way of diminishing in any way reducing
this character
but the contrary uh to the contrary of
setting it in full light
i think of the somewhat usurped title of
barrez's last book
only despite all this it seems to me
difficult not to go further and here i
do not know if the author of the spirit
of medieval philosophy shares my view
despite everything else the most
important problem put to philosophy is
that of researching how this fee
condition of reason by dogma is possible
it does not seem to me
that philosophy can or should be
confined to noting it as a simple fact
or a datum of experience and it seems to
me that the problem's general solution
should not at all be sought in a
rationalization of dogma mr gilson is a
hundred times right to denounce that as
incompatible with an authentic
christianity
but matters are entirely different with
a metaphysical elucidation of reason
itself or of the rational content that
causes its radically mysterious
character to emerge
this might at first appear obscure but
let us not forget that for a christian
nature is a created nature it cannot be
a question of attributing to it that's
sort of implicit and otherwise
unintelligible ipseity that na that
naturalism generally incapable of
defining itself invests itself with
one would hardly believe it seems to me
the extent that the idea or the pseudo
idea of something that would be
completely natural or that would be from
itself comes among non-christian
philosophers to qualify in a clandestine
way if i may say so nature considered in
its massive unity this completely
natural is like a confused nearly
affective expression of logical identity
that is of a rationality understood
in its poorest and most formal sense but
from the christian point of view this
cannot subsist for a second to suppose
even and this is what seems to me more
than dubious
that one could attribute some sort of
obscenity to nature it is then a
derivative ipsaid in reality fallacious
at every point completely irreducible to
the profane pseudonotion of completely
natural
but our reason a created reason ordered
to the intelligence of created nature
must by deepening itself recognize what
in it exceeds the domain of adequacy to
itself it cannot grasp itself it seems
to me
except as radically unequal to itself
quite far from being able to rest as
certain of descartes continues if not
descartes himself have believed in an
intellectual intuition where it would be
be not only commensurable but entirely
transparent to itself
if from all the varied analyses i've put
before you mr jillson writes i may
venture to extract a conclusion from the
respective conclusions i should say that
the essential result of a christian
philosophy is a deeply considered
affirmation of a reality and goodness
intrinsic to nature such as the greeks
lacking knowledge of its source and end
only dimly foreshadowed
this declaration seems to me as central
in the first place because it puts to an
end the absurd legends accredited for so
long by michelle and his disciples and
in a general way by those who without
suspected confused catholicism and
jansonism
in the second place because it places
the accent precisely and in an inter at
least indirect manner on the mystery
hidden in things and in reason itself
the mystery that seems to me to be the
secret treasury of all christian
philosophy we can hardly exaggerate the
damaging consequences of confusing
catholicism and jansonism granted the
reformation had already contributed to
aggravating or obscuring the situation
even more with it for the first time
appeared this conception of a grace that
saves a man without changing him
of a justice that redeems corrupted
nature without restoring it of a christ
who pardons the sinner for
self-inflicted wounds but does not heal
them
instead
in the first centuries of the church
to be a christian was essentially to
maintain the right distance from money
who denied nature's radical goodness and
pelagius who denied along with the
wounds that had received the necessity
of a grace to heal them
later as saint bonaventure and saint
thomas ardent defenders as they were of
grace will no be no less defenders of
quote the nature that god made doubly
precious since god himself died to save
it it is not they who will let us forget
along with his misery the greatness of
man the more he is aware of its dignity
the higher feeling he will have for its
glory and indeed if he is to be able to
refer it to god at all he must perforce
know something about it to possess what
one knows nothing at all
what what glory can there be in that it
is saint bernard who asks that here we
are in my view at the very heart of the
problem of christian philosophy mr
jill's home perfectly indicates the
intrinsic coherence the legitimacy of
the great undertaking of the thinkers of
the middle ages
how could they have thought that the
science of grace could obstruct that of
nature when grace was there only to
perfect nature having first restored it
but conversely since nature is there but
as the subject and the point of
application of grace how could the
science of one if properly conducted
conflict with conflict with the science
of the other the only thing to do is to
attempt the work to attempt it it was at
once indispensable to start from the
only known philosophy that is to say
greek philosophy and impossible to rest
content with it
from this point of view mr brehere's
thesis seems decidedly untenable it
seems that medieval philosophy had shown
at the same time a degree of solidarity
and an independence in relation to
ancient thought without which it would
have failed at the mission it had
assigned itself
perhaps one will counter that is not
where the question lies nobody accuses
st thomas or st bonaventure of having
poorly realized his intention everything
rests on knowing whether this intention
in what is its specific end in it is not
foreign and even in a certain sense
contradictory to this preoccupation with
pure truth with pure rational
elucidation that alone must dominate the
mind of a philosopher worthy of that
name
in reality we'd rediscover here the
threatening formula cited earlier one
can no more speak of a christian
philosophy than a christian mathematics
or a christian physics but as soon as we
seek to tightly grasp the meaning of
this formula this formula seductive at
first by its apparent rigor
it seems to me that this meaning
vanishes
does he mean to say that philosophy
bears on essences and on intelligible
concatenations whereas christianity is a
life i grant this
but this life itself appears to hang on
certain affirmations about the
metaphysical reality of the world and
that which exceeds it precisely he will
say i imagine those are the affirmations
that of a creator god a god accessible
to love and to pity for his create
creatures finally and above all of a god
who makes himself man in order to save
men those are the very affirmations that
reveal themselves incompatible with the
demands of an authentically
philosophical thought
but on this plane
i repeat we want not to appeal to
history saying that a christian
philosophy or a philosophy with
christian pretensions existed
more strictly speaking was believed to
exist or not it has only been a false
semblance it is as not having been
here then it is not it is not in any way
the historian of philosophy who
expresses himself but rather the
rationalist who distrusts appearances
then putting it in an analogous way
right there wrongly and for my part i am
persuaded that this is wrongly
there could have been actually
astrologers that is individuals who
believed in astrology it matters little
astrology is not because it cannot be
but by pronouncing oneself in this way
a priori on what is possible or not
legitimate or not in philosophy one sets
oneself precisely outside the very
conditions of a philosophical activity
as real as it may be what is specific in
to philosophy in opposition to any other
specialized sphere of knowledge is that
it does not derive itself from any other
jurisdiction superior to itself
understood i mean on the natural plane
that would assign it such and such
limits
such and such a limited sphere of
application it is certainly not
necessary to remind mr brahier the role
that the idea of the mind's infinite
freedom has played in the works of the
post conscience
but i cannot keep myself from asking
whether he has sufficiently discerned
what i will call this idea's perforating
power
in relation to any intelligible cosmos
conceived directly or not on the model
of the philosophers of antiquity
we must go even further in this idea
about which we would have to carry out
much work to establish that it is not at
its basis of christian origin resides
what is needed to break with the even
the pretensions of a pan-logisticist
reason even a hegelian reason what is
needed to re-establish on the ruins of
any system centered on absolute
knowledge the fundamental data for the
spiritually disinherited use
data that would be claimed to have been
repressed and relegated into who knows
what being who knows what junk drawer
what dust bin and here i would cite a
passage from mr blondel's the problem to
the
philosophy catholic that seems to me to
do justice once and for all to so much
partisanship and obstinacy mr blondel
rightly denounces what is artificial and
false and opposing to each other two
caricatures each is irrational as the
other the hellenic cosmos conceived as
the place of all harmony and all
intelligibility and the christian
universe conceived as a scandal as a
permanent challenge to thought
quote
let us consider then the animating idea
of christian thought not desiccated to
the point of death in hardened tissues
but moving in its real and malleable
continuity
under this unifying and concrete aspect
what have we by progressive chastenings
set under the idea and sometimes under
the name of catholic philosophy
is it a system of concepts an ideology a
palace of abstractions no it is a life
and a life agreeing in concrete with the
most sublime history with a dogma that
can be called dramatic
in god in the universe in humanity down
to each consciousness in order to render
everything intelligible
justifiable good from the origins to the
eternal consummation of the work of
power and of charity
is this therefore what is less rational
less intelligible less beautiful less
good less perfect than the changing
immutable than eternal time than the
periodic returns of the great year then
the fixity of essences and the milieu of
the universal becoming of things
so that's gabriel marcel's two-part
review of uh etienne gilson's book
the gifford lectures the spirit of
medieval philosophy the reason why he
talks about it is two is because it was
originally released in two volumes you
you can get it in translation in english
in a single volume
and the gifford lectures are of course
these very important lectures um that
are are given yearly uh many many
philosophers have
given them including gabriel marcel
later right
and um joseon
chose to use his as
the spirit of medieval philosophy and
continued the discussions about the
christian philosophy debate
so
that's the little selection from reason
fulfilled by revelation that we're
looking at today um i'll stick around
for a bit of q a um mark says is going
to have to pick up this book
yeah i mean it's it's a it's a good book
to get it's a little unfortunately
catholic university uh of america press
did almost nothing to promote it and
priced it a little bit out of a lot of
people's reach you know um i was hoping
that it would become a
research tool for scholars who wanted to
go beyond just you know jill song's
spirit of medieval philosophy
and uh mara tens also translated the
problem of christian philosophy and a
few
articles that have been translated here
and there and and provide you know a
much more representative cross-section
of these debates
um so far it's sold you know a little
over 500 copies i think half to
libraries after individuals
um
and uh
yeah so
it's there's a catch 22 as well it's not
going to get turned into a soft cover
unless it sells enough copies where cua
press
thinks that it's profitable for them to
to do so
i am actually going to talk to them
about maybe doing like an audio book
but i'm i'm willing to bet they're going
to say no to that because they are you
know a traditional academic press and
academic presses are very
very conservative when it comes to those
sorts of things unfortunately
but i probably will be writing another
book
about these debates down the line
that will
you know
we'll publish it in a different format
to make it a lot more available
so anybody have any questions about the
debates about gabriel marcel about uh
jill so about the ideas that are being
referenced i'm happy to
take any of those on
this is a debate that's taking place in
the 1930s largely among francophone
people it spilled over into italian and
spanish and english and other languages
even somebody writing in latin believe
it or not there's an article
that was in a journal i forget exactly
what it was but it was written there
uh joseph does
gabriel marcel see greek philosophy
something that can be displaced for
catholic christians i don't know what
displaced would mean in that case i
think you'd have to follow up
um i'm not sure what what that team what
that term would would indicate
um certainly he think he he recognizes
as does jill song that
greek philosophy is not a single thing
there is no essence of greek philosophy
as opposed to christianity or something
like that people who talk you know like
in in terms of athens versus jerusalem
are engaging with abstractions
um and we we know quite you know clearly
that
a lot of greek philosophy was used not
just you know in the high middle ages by
the scholastics but
um
throughout the patristic era going into
the the rest of the middle ages um even
when it's not necessarily being
referenced it's um it's being used by
christian philosophers like you know
saint anselm for example who had at his
disposal
um
seneca and cicero and the other people
that the monks are copying through them
you can actually get a lot of plate on
aristotle
in addition to you know stoics and
epicureans and skeptics and people like
that
so any other i mean if you want to
follow up joseph and say what you mean
by displaced i can i can maybe answer
the question better
um otherwise anybody else have any
questions or comments that they want to
uh
get addressed answered before we sign
off
i'll say this while people are
thinking about if they want to write
anything i'm i'm actually enjoying quite
a bit um
rereading this stuff because most of
these people especially gabriel marcel
were quite good and thoughtful
writers and it was quite a challenge to
you know put them their their french
stuff into english but it was also
something that i i took a lot of joy in
while i was while i was doing so many
years back i mean it's ten years since
this book came out the process of
translation work was done i would say
around
2008 2009
you know and then it was a matter of
you know doing all the things that you
have to do with academic writing you
know the proof reading and jumping
through hoops and stuff like that making
a index
yeah dan says cua should publish a
kindle version
they should
but
you know and and you know
they're dumb not to do it but that's
that's cua um
traditional academic publishers are
you know they're very stuck in an old
model of of doing things and i it's
interesting because cua recently
there was somebody there
who was like we're going to do things
differently we're going to like start
using social media
and i you know i follow them in social
media and their social media is crap you
know uh as is the case for so many
places and i was like hey i i would be
happy to like write a blog post about my
book or do something like that
and somebody was like yeah that sounds
cool
i haven't heard from them since in like
the two or three months
since that one single thing came out i i
think they they don't get that
we live in an internet saturated world
where you have to put your feet forward
and actually
you know get your message out there and
and you know you can't just like like
it's not like just going and posting a
flyer somewhere and then hoping somebody
will see it you got to keep posting that
flyer you got to keep um you know
doing the work and i think a lot of
academic presses just don't have people
who understand how to do that work
it's unfortunate because
academic presses are dying you know
uh we may not see too many of them
left other than the really big flagships
like you know
university of chicago or cambridge
university or places like that but
um there have been significant cutbacks
and a lot of university presses over the
years
going going back decades so
all right any other questions comments
issues people want to bring up
no all right well then we'll call this
one to an end
uh hope all of you have a great rest of
your day and we'll do this again next
week it's going to be atn bourne's a
very short piece um but but an important
one on a christian philosophy that would
be philosophical published in the
journal esprit so i'll see you next time
for that one